hey guys how's it going i am db woodside
and i play amena deal
on netflix's lucifer hi i'm amy garcia
and i play ella lopez
hi i'm rachel harris and i play dr linda
martin
i am leslie and brunt and i play mazaki
i
am kevin alejandro and i play detective
dan espinoza aka detective douche
today we're going to be taking a
buzzfeed quiz to find out
which lucifer character we actually are
in our real lives
here's the first question in the spirit
of lucifer
pick one of the seven deadly sins lust
envy sloth greed cried
wrath gluttony or to be honest none of
these
i think my pride gets in the way a lot
of times well if it's food related for
sure gluttony
mine is gonna be lust let's move on to
the next question i don't wanna talk
about it
i am very much like mays that being said
what would you pick
wrath i knew it to be honest i think i'm
going to have to choose wrath as well
silent wrath exactly that's what i'm
going to say like i'm silent and i let
things
sort of you know play their course and
then if it's something that i that i
feel that i have to stand up for then
beware the wrath of alejandro choose
something with
devil in the name devil's food cake
the devil wears prada devil in the white
city
by eric larson or the devil went down to
georgia
deviled eggs or devil in a blue dress
i'm going with devil whisperer because
i love prada and that makes total sense
and i love shoes you're in my closet you
guys i have prada right here
oh my gosh unless leanne i'm gonna give
this one to you what do you think i'm
gonna choose
i feel like devil's food cake no you
don't know me
i'm gonna choose and i'm gonna tell you
why i'm gonna choose the devil went down
to georgia
because that's the only song i know how
to sing karaoke
definitely double decked i got
food on the mind at all times but you
wouldn't pick
devil's food cake you know what range
that's i'm gonna change my answer
you have an excellent point i have a
total sweet tooth yeah
devil's food cake so i think i'm gonna
go with devil and a blue dress honestly
i'm gonna have to go with uh my man
denzel and uh don cheadle devil
in a blue dress pick something to watch
that features
twins sister sister parent trap
i know this much is true the social
network
adaptation or it takes two okay
well for me this is such an obvious
pick for me i played a fifth year senior
one season on sister sister for me it's
a no-brainer
what do you think it what do you guys
think it is if we had to guess
parents wrapped there's adaptation
which is a fantastic movie i'm gonna
have to go with adaptation
i think because of the joke with leslie
and danny sister sister
i also loved that show growing up i did
watch tia and tamara i think
i'm gonna go with the parent trap
because i freaking love that movie
how would you cope after a rough day
confide in your friend
or partner would you just sweat it out
at the gym
would you have a drink take a bath
distract yourself with work or just
run away i would say spit it out i'll
say spit it out
sweat it out a good one i'm gonna have
to go with confide in
my partner i'm gonna let you guys guess
which one i would do i would guess
sweat it out of the gym what do you do
there you go oh yeah
okay so which one do you think i would
do i think you would take a bath
get in the bathtub and just soak and
just
really take your time in there and do a
little self-care self-love
with a drink in your hands that sounds
amazing honestly it's confusing
um and a friend oh wow okay how would i
cope after a rough day
i think you would distract yourself with
work you would come home and start
creating
writing just just to get your mind off
of
whatever craziness was in your day
you're right i'll just throw myself
into writing and you know creating and
honor this upcoming musical episode
choose a famous musical mamma mia
wicked hamilton the lion king
cats or the book of mormon i have to go
with hamilton
i'm gonna jump on the same train as
rachel that would be hamilton
i was not able to ever see hamilton on
stage
so the first time i saw it on uh disney
plus i was blown
the away that musical is
so good everyone in there is
unbelievable
it just left such a mark on me i'm ready
to get on stage and like
rap man i mean like let's do this well
i've never seen it
i will watch it so i can't pick it
because i haven't seen it
for me it's a no-brainer lion king
hamill tony
come on come on i'm gonna have to go
with wicked oh
i haven't seen it oh okay oh man don't
get me wrong hamilton's amazing but
wicked i
am a huge fan of the wizard of oz and
any sort of adaptation that we can get
of that story and those characters i
mean 100 which
character would you trust the most with
a secret dan
eve amenadale ella linda
mays definitely not maize
[Laughter]
it would have to be between dr
linda because she's a therapist and
that's all she does is listen to secrets
and a minute deal because he's like
god's favorite i'm gonna go with them in
a deal
i would probably say i made a deal too
linda linda
yeah can i pick myself but i also would
pick him in a deal
amena deal if you told him a secret that
he somehow
felt morally compromising yes thank you
yeah he was black yeah okay so um so
let's all just pick linda i'm excited
yeah
linda pick another crime solving show we
have monk
veronica mars true detective luther
psych or murder she wrote i'm gonna jump
right there because this one is real
easy for me i'm gonna say luther because
idris is the man and that is one of my
favorite shows
i think it just has to be veronica mars
you know i think she was just like
super smart i just liked that she was
like young and smart i'm gonna go with
monk because i love tony chalub
and i just think he was brilliant in
that and i liked how
quirky he was and weird i gotta go hands
down true detective
name that first season whoa finally
what is your deepest desire to be rich
to be famous to be loved
to be beautiful to change the world to
be powerful
to change the world changing the world
mine is to change the world
i think we often agree amy what's you
what is yours
to change the world
i got me i got a mana deal i got him in
a deal
i got lucifer
i got linda you are confident fun and
embassable yourself you're also a loyal
friend who puts
others needs before your own i agree
with that 100
i got linda because i'm quiet uh you're
extremely caring
and you just want everyone you love to
be happy i'm gonna have to agree with
that
i think this is a pretty accurate
buzzfeed challenge you got
amen a deal you're an honest person who
always strives to do the right thing
you're driven loyal and would do
anything for your family
this is true you got lucifer you love
the finer things in life and are all
about having a good time
enjoying every moment and indulging
yourself whoever
wrote this is really good
you